the way i create a thriving environment here
at Filtrous it's just about letting people
be their own boss not micromanage and feel
this is like almost second home to them
you can come in here and pretty much share your
ideas share your thoughts have your opinions
speak them freely they're always welcome we make
it what we want to make it and we want to preserve
that because you want to have this happy upbeat
space sometimes it's very difficult to have that
day in day out all day eight hours a day um you
know we have personal stuff going on or you have
work stuff going on and and i think one of the
ways that i tell or i share with my colleagues
is imagine a tree right outside the door
and you're having like a bad day you know
whatever it is and you just hang your [ __ ]
on the tree before you walk through the door
just like to envision that and just like leave
your dirty laundry just hanging outside the doors
and when you are happy or you're smiling or just
like thinking about good thoughts it comes across
as well for me i try to always have background
music playing on my radio on my desk because
that to me that's my happy or i'll write smile
on my paper on my desk every day i write smile
and i put a happy face so if something happens
i'll look down and i'm like okay i'll smile
and those are things you know it's just creating
little things that are gonna help you stay
cheerful throughout your day for me what makes
filtrus different than everywhere that i've worked
is obviously david his support with all his
employees he literally wants everybody that
walks through that door be successful and he
genuinely feels that in his heart and you can
see that come across and to me that's somebody
who's very passionate very caring and that's
very different than any other place that
I've ever worked i feel like i have been
in corporate America most of my life you're just
pretty much a number it's really hard to get
that personal one-on-one feel from the owner let
alone the CEO for me it's gonna sound super cliche
but it has turned my whole life around and this is
the best way to describe it i feel like i had been
walking around life with my eyes closed this place
kind of opened my eyes to this whole new world
before i came to work for Filtrous it was
you know basically you go to work you do the
routine job you go home at the end of the day
not until did i come here did he really push me
to really start thinking and focusing on my own
personal growth it's just been like literally
life-changing we all have goals we all have things
that need to get done on the daily in order to
keep moving the business forward but doesn't
mean that you can't enjoy your day while you're
accomplishing your goals i help people have a
voice by pulling them aside and allowing them to
feel like they can express the negative along
with the positive if they have something that
didn't sit well with them i try to let them
know you can come to me or you can go to
anybody else that you feel comfortable enough
with sharing that you would want to work here
at Filtrous because it is still a small company
that's getting ready to explode and not only that
it's a place that you can come and be part
of something that's gonna be really big I've
seen it already and we're not even at scratching
the surface yet to have seen the company go from
not only four employees to 20 plus employees now
but seeing that little building that looked like
it could have been gone the next day to being
in this building that we now own and seeing the
growth and the vision that David shared with
me from day one come to life is super exciting
my piece of advice to a new employee is the sky's
the limit and really honestly it is the god honest
truth that you can make this place what you want
it to be I've seen people go from the warehouse to
become senior lab techs I've seen people go from
the warehouse to become sales reps there's no
rules here no traditional rules that you have to
have a degree or some kind of background we will
give you those opportunities as long as you're
willing to work for them the sky's the limit here